our
approach here and our strategic approach
here is to
continue to communicate directly stay
closely uh
interwo interlocked with the israelis
with partners on the ground
to do everything we can to bring an end
to the conflict we have seen
reports of a move toward a potential
ceasefire
that's clearly encouraging obviously we
can't get ahead of any agreements that
may be brokered
but i would say that to go back to
answer your original question there
darlene we've had
uh we've now held more than 80
engagements with senior leaders in
israel the palestinian authority and
across the region
either in person or by phone and
again that our view and our approach has
been
to use our the role of the united states
and the relationships uh with countries
on the ground
to conduct our efforts quietly and
through diplomatic channels
do you have anything on a call between
the president today and uh
lcc and egypt i expect we'll have a
readout shortly i can confirm they had a
call
and just to remind you part of that
engagement is a reflection of what we've
been talking about a bit in this
briefing room was the important role
that a number of countries in the region
can play including the egyptians in
bringing an end to the conflict
and they have an important role to play
in influencing hamas hence
the president had a conversation with
him this morning i expect we'll have a
readout shortly
just one quickly if i can switch to
infrastructure
senator capito has raised the
possibility of
using unspent covet 19 money to pay for
infrastructure
is that something the white house would
be open an approach the white house
would be open to
well again i know there'll be a range of
ideas and proposals that will come
forward
from senator capito from other
republicans and other democrats as well
the president's bottom line as you've
heard me say a few times before is that
he does not want to raise taxes on
people making less than four hundred
thousand
dollars a year we certainly and that
scenario would need to assess
whether these funds are needed and not
take them away from
uh fighting the pandemic that we
continue to battle every day
go ahead thank you jen couple of topics
quickly first uh house republicans are
claiming that they have
uh significant circumstantial evidence
that cobit 19
originated in a lab has the white house
seen any circumstantial evidence that it
did not
originate in a lab well i think first i
would caution you against disproving
a negative there which is never the
responsible approach in our view
whenever
when it comes to getting to the bottom
of the root causes of a pandemic that
has killed
hundreds of thousands of people in the
united states i will say that our view
continues to be that there needs to be
an independent transparent investigation
uh
and that needs to happen with the
cooperation and data provided
from the chinese government we don't
have enough information
at this point to make an assessment and
part of the reason some of these
lawmakers say that is is because
china is not cooperating right now at
what point
would president biden call president xi
and say we've got
587 883 dead americans we're just trying
to figure out
if this happened if colby originated in
one of your labs
let us in well i would say that we have
made that call
publicly many times we have conveyed
that privately and we have certainly
communicated that
they were not transparent from the
beginning that's not acceptable
there's an opportunity now in the next
stage of this effort
for them to be transparent to
participate in international
investigation that can
bring a conclusion to the origins and
provide information that we
republicans democrats everyone in this
country would love to access
um nordstrom but i know that there's a
lot of talk about normal stream and
keystone and i'm just trying to help our
people understand it is there well yes
uh president biden
blocked the keystone xl pipeline here
because
he said it would undermine us climate
leadership and undercut our ability to
urge
other countries to take ambitious
climate action so how is he urging other
countries
to take ambitious climate action if he's
letting other countries build
north stream too first we're hardly
letting any country or
other countries build nordstrom 2. when
the president took office 95
of this pipeline was built we've
continued to convey
that we believe it's a bad uh a bad idea
a bad
plan and we have also put in place and
taken actions over the last several days
to make that clear in large part because
our view is that it's a russian
geopolitical project that threatens
european energy security and that of
ukraine and
the east and eastern flank nato allies
and partners
hence there's a geopolitical concern
about this pipeline
and we've taken uh steps over the last
several days to make that clear
so a lot of concerns and it seemed like
there was
the ability by the us government to
sanction some officials
to stop the project at like 95 percent
but you're not doing it
we're going to be able to stop a project
in another country that's had been
built in 95 making it more difficult
with the sanctions on some of these
officials involved well we have imposed
sanctions on four russian entities four
russian vessels that engaged in
sanctionable
activities we've also imposed sanctions
on nine vessels belonging to the russian
government
this is the largest number of entities
listed under this act to date so we have
certainly take significant step
and the major public private channels
are opposition to this plan and then
quickly on israel progressives in the
house
are hoping to block 735 million dollars
worth of weapons to israel would the
president ever go along with that
well let me first say that the state
department is overseas
arms sales any conference of those
specific details or notifications that
may
have gone to congress uh so i would let
them speak to that specific proposal
you're asking about
i will say that we've had a long abiding
security and strategic relationship with
israel that has been
certainly the case for decades as a
candidate though president biden boasted
that he was the only one in the race
who'd ever brought world leaders
together to solve
a major problem there's a major problem
in the middle east right now
so why aren't the leaders and the people
there benefiting
from all of his foreign policy
experience do you not count the 80
engagements we've had with countries
around the world including the
president's call with
the leader of egypt the four calls he's
had with uh
the israeli prime minister and the fact
that there have been reports of a
ceasefire
of a movement toward a ceasefire i would
say do you not count
him telling benjamin netanyahu who he
says he's known for a long time
uh to that he wanted a ds or that he
expected a de-escalation
by yesterday and netanyahu just ignoring
him
well first of all i would say that we
are uh continuing to work toward that
and that uh we have believed that
they're in a position to start winding
their operations
down and certainly that is what we've
been conveying and that is what we
expect
to happen uh in short order so last one
the president says that foreign policy
is something he's done
his entire life is it working
i would say uh that if you look at the
fact that the american
the global community believes that
america's back has a seat at the table
that we're going to continue to lead in
the efforts to get the climate crisis
under control to lead in the efforts in
engagement around the world
certainly bringing about an end to this
conflict but also
moving toward diplomacy in as it relates
to north korea
and moving toward a place where the
united states is
returned to the place of being a leader
in global forum as we hope to be at nato
i would say we're certainly uh working
on changing the tide of the last four
years go ahead
um there are decidedly mixed signals
coming out of both the iranians and the
europeans
on the chances of a nuclear deal being
struck can you tell us who's right
well i don't know if i can i don't know
if i'm going to take uh assess in that
exact term
in that exact phrasing but i will tell
you this um
we remain engaged as a party in these
discussions
obviously our discussions as you know
from following this are
uh through indirect talks through the
europeans we continue to believe that
our efforts as it relates to uh bringing
an end uh
or or preventing iran from acquiring a
nuclear weapon need to happen through
diplomatic channels
and those talks and engagements are
continuing we always know
from having lived through these
negotiations before there will be bumpy
roads there will be different
assessments but we're continuing
to work toward progress on south korea
the president
is seeking to tap into the u.s vaccine
supply as part of this visit
how does the white house view such
requests from from advanced economies
like south korea
is there a higher bar um
can you give us some some some color on
that on all those requests
you mean just for clarification so you
mean the president of south korea is
looking to
tap into our vaccine supply uh you know
i certainly
we certainly expect that uh the leaders
will discuss
ways the united states can support uh
the so that south koreans f
south south support south koreans fight
against covet 19
as well as how we can work together to
combat the pandemic around
the world and certainly they will raise
a range of issues i know they've noted
that this is one that they
intend to raise which is hence why
you're asking me about it uh
i will say that as it relates to the
vaccine supply that we've announced
we're going to be sharing
with the world we will look at that and
we will make decisions which are still
ongoing
uh with a couple of criteria in mind how
to do it equitably how to ensure we're
reaching
uh parts of the world that need help the
most how to do it in a way that's
fair and has a regional balance
so i don't expect that assessment to be
made in advance of tomorrow uh but
certainly
uh we welcome the opportunity to discuss
with them how we can work together to
address the global pandemic
one more question uh john kerry and
others have called on south korea to
to double its 20 30 targets for carbon
cutting emissions
saying it won't go far enough to meet
the 2050 goals should we expect
any movement on that should we expect
south korea to to come a little bit
higher on those 23
2030 goals as part of these talks well
we are working with south korea in areas
of mutual interest and
certainly uh climate ambition addressing
the climate crisis that's facing the
global community is part of that
um sectoral decarbonization and clean
energy deployment we expect will be a
part of
the discussion uh and we are looking
forward to enhancing technical exchanges
on economy-wide
decarbonization aligned with the global
goal to achieve net zero greenhouse gas
emissions so
i certainly expect that addressing the
climate crisis what we can do mutually
what steps they can take perhaps what
steps we can take will be part of the
discussions but in terms of what
the outcome of it will be tomorrow i'm
not in a position to get ahead of that
go ahead thank you jen understanding
that there have been more than 60 phone
calls between 80
minutes okay 80 between the
administration and
regional leaders why is the president
and vice president
now reaching out to their regional
counterparts beyond
prime minister netanyahu why not make
those some of the first phone calls
well the president spoke with uh prime
minister abbas just
he spoke with him last week already
these conversations
well i would say kristin that these
conversations have been happening at a
very high level the secretary of state
other high level members of the
administration our national security
advisor we've read out many of these
calls not every single one but we've
read out
many of them as well and we have felt
that those conversations are
constructive
uh that they have been
helpful partners and working to bring an
end to get to the point we're at now
where we are working to unwind we're
encouraging
the unwinding and the end of the
conflict on the ground and
there are moments when it's the right
moment for the president to have a call
directly with a
global leader himself this is one of the
president could the president
have tried to move forward with this
ceasefire
earlier if he had started reaching out
to lcc
and his other partners in the region
several days ago
we have been very closely aligned and
touched and working in lockstep
with our partners in the region that is
not required but kristin
the way diplomacy works that does not
always require a call from a global
leader
we have been working in lockstep with
them at still a very high level
to bring an end to the violence i bring
it into the conflict on the ground
and they share a desire to do exactly
that and there's no question that their
relationship uh ability to engage with
hamas
ensures that they can play a very
powerful and impactful role in this
regard
but the reason let me just say one more
one more point the reason that we're at
this point
in terms of the evolving uh
conversations
and statements and readouts that we have
put out is because the situation on the
ground has also evolved and that
those readouts reflect that i should be
very clear about
where things stand is it the
administration's understanding that both
sides have now agreed to
the ceasefire at this point we have seen
reports
of a potential ceasefire which we
certainly see as encouraging
but we are not in a position to get
ahead of any agreements that may
be brokered confirmed there isn't no
decision no but we've certainly seen
those reports
that those are encouraging that's
certainly what we're encouraging and
we're what we are working toward
ask you about the commission to
investigate what happened
on january 6th obviously the bill passed
through the house
it is facing very steep odds in the
senate and house speaker nancy pelosi
has said
that if necessary she would be open to
moving forward
with a commission that would only have
the support of democrats would the white
house
support that and have any concerns that
the optics of that would ultimately
undercut any findings well we're not at
that point yet and we've certainly seen
the speaker's comments what i will say
since you gave me
the opportunity is that the attack on
the capitol on january 6th
was an unprecedented assault on our
democracy it demands a full and
independent investigation into what
happened
this is not a political issue in the
president's view this is a question of
how we secure
our democracy and the rule of law so
it's incredibly disappointing to see how
many republi
how many representatives have opted to
turn this into a political issue
instead of doing what's right for our
country and our constitution and they
still have the opportunity to do the
right thing
would you be open to the possibility of
a commission there hasn't been a vote in
the senate yet obviously our hope is
that
senate republicans do the right thing
put
partisan politics aside uh vote in a way
that supports
the preservation of our democracy of our
constitution uh they have the
opportunity to do that
if they don't have it we'll have a
conversation about it finally
there is a lot of skepticism on capitol
hill that there will in fact
be um a bill that they'll pass the
george floyd bill
by the anniversary of george floyd's
death
next week has the white house accepted
that that it is
all but an impossibility at this point
that it'll pass and what will the
president do on the anniversary
well i don't have anything to preview
yet uh in terms of the president's
schedule next week we will certainly
mark the anniversary as it was a moment
that impacted
millions of americans and certainly the
president on a personal
level i will say kristin that obviously
we are in close touch and we
certainly defer to the expectations of
the key negotiators here and
i would note that senator booker has
indicated that there is good energy to
the talks senator scott has said that
the key for us
is to making is to keep making progress
and we certainly support
those efforts the president talked about
the george floyd justice and policing
act in his joint session speech
put a marker down because he feels it's
important to be bold to be ambitious
uh and that's exactly what he feels uh
we're hopefully working toward
sure go ahead so yesterday president
biden told the prime minister that he
wanted to see significant de-escalation
yesterday and on a path to ceasefire
yesterday so did he see that significant
de-escalation
and does he believe they are on the path
to the cease-fire
well uh caitlyn i would say we're not
going to give a day by day grade here
uh of the efforts but i will say that
our objective
is to uh is is to continue to push and
encourage
uh all parties on the ground israel of
course the president has spoken to prime
minister netanyahu as you know four
times
more than any other world leader and to
start winding
their operations down we have seen
reports of a potential ceasefire
that is certainly encouraging and we
believe that they are at the point where
they certainly should be positioned
to bring an end to this conflict but
again as i started off conveying
you know we're also in a place where uh
we want to bring this to an end
as quickly as possible that is clearly
our objective
but we are only on about den 10 or 11
here
when we look back at 2014 that was about
51 days
and we're gonna continue to press behind
the scenes press through intensive quiet
diplomacy to bring an end to the
conflict
because he did set the deadline of
significant de-escalation yesterday so
i'm just wondering if they met that mark
to his liking again i'm not going to
give a
public evaluation from the president of
day by day actions what i can tell you
is that
we are continuing to work behind the
scenes
through these 80 engagements with senior
officials to advocate for
to convey that they should be in a
position now to start winding their
operations down
and that is what we are hopeful to see
okay and what are the national security
reasons for waving the sanctions on the
company and the ceo behind
nordstrom 2. uh i know we made this
announcement from the state department
just
yesterday and they certainly spoke to
this from their end
we also put in place a number of
sanctions as you know
uh on russian officials uh and russians
who were engaged
uh in this um uh in the building of
nordstrom 2 to send a clear message that
we think that
this is a bad deal that it is a
geopolitical
um uh plan that uh we feel puts
our uh eastern flank nato allies and
partners and ukraine
uh at risk uh so that is why we put
those in place
uh what's the reason for waving the
sanctions
we certainly have an important vital
relationship with
leaders in germany and we make a range
of
decisions through a range of global
global factors
okay my last question about 15 days ago
i think
michael fanon who is a dc metropolitan
police officer who was there
on january the 6th uh was beaten tased
they stole his badge you know suffered a
lot of trauma he says that he still is
living through
he says he sent you a letter about 15
days ago talking about the emotional
anxiety that he still struggles with
on a daily basis and saying it's time to
fully recognize
the actions of the officers on that day
so i was just wondering if the white
house has a response to him
i i'm happy to check on the status of
the letter uh obviously
the president's view is that the number
of officers who lost their lives
paid a tremendous sacrifice uh for
uh on a day that will be a stain on our
democracy for many years to come
and certainly many who survived um uh
this will be
a long lasting trauma i'd have to check
on the letter and the status of that
okay thank you thanks jen you've said a
couple times that you believe that the
israelis are in a position to start
winding their operations down and that's
what the administration expects to
happen in short quarter
have the israelis conveyed that they are
going to wind down
operations and can you define short
order what type of timeline are you
looking for
well i will let them convey what they
feel they've accomplished
our views we believe the israelis have
achieved
significant military objectives that
they laid out to achieve
in relation to protecting their people
and to responding to
the thousands of rocket attacks from
hamas
um and so that's why in part that we
feel
they are in a position to start winding
their operation
down uh we continue to believe that they
have a right to defend themselves but
this
is uh where we see again our evolution
of
what the readouts that we're sending of
what we're conveying what the
president's conveying directly the prime
minister
is also a reflection of what we're
seeing on the ground and what our
officials who are working in close in
lockstep with both israeli officials
palestinians others are also seeing on
the ground so it's a reflection of all
of that
but in terms of their assessment uh of
that i will certainly leave that to them
and obviously our objective is to work
toward a ceasefire
so there has not been a message from the
israelis to the administration that they
are going i'm not going to read out
their messages from them
they can do that i can read out what we
are conveying to them why is the
president
not publicly calling for an immediate
ceasefire rather than a path
to a ceasefire you know the
de-escalation not
right now stop this what what is the
thinking behind that
i think the president's been clear he
wants to see a wind down of this
of the violence and end to the violence
and uh a
winding of their operations down as
quickly as possible and lead to a
ceasefire as quickly as possible so i
don't think he's
attempting to mince words there and what
he hopes the outcome to be
are there any consequences if israel
does not show progress toward that
de-escalation
toward the path to cease fire our focus
is on getting to a path to a ceasefire
and bringing into the violence to the
suffering of the israeli people the
palestinian people
many people in the region so i'm not
going to get ahead of that to predict
consequences
go ahead i'll go ahead jenny sorry um
uh on infrastructure senator capito uh
said that
she expects a counter offer from the
white house tomorrow can you confirm
this is the deadline
is there a deadline for tomorrow to make
a counteroffer we do expect we had
constructive conversations at a staff
level
on tuesday on the hill with senator
capito other
ranking members with steve burchetti and
louise atterl
secretary buddha judge secretary
raimondo and we expect those
conversations to continue tomorrow
and then on another piece of legislation
um on the hill
that i know is a priority of yours the
endless frontier act
um obviously you guys care a lot but
yeah semiconductors
um it seems like the negotiations have
hit a couple hiccups which you know is
kind of normal
um but at what point is the white house
getting involved in smoothing the subway
because i know
you know this was supposed to go on a
faster track than your infrastructure
proposal
are you guys involved at all through
your ledger affairs team
um or do you lead this all to senator
schumer we're absolutely involved we're
strong supporters of the endless
frontiers act as was evidenced by the
um statement of administration policy we
put out earlier this week and
um we are hopeful and looking forward to
signing it into law
if are you behind the scenes pushing to
resolve the hiccups that are
currently holding up our legislative
team is closely involved with members
um and with their staff on moving it
forward
one last one also on infrastructure um
if you can
uh lay out what the white house and the
president himself was doing
um to urge uh congressional democrats to
support his proposed tax increase
increases uh what to pro to
i'm sorry say that one more time what
the president what the president and
your
leg affairs team is uh how that outreach
what type of outreach you're doing with
hill democrats
on the proposed tax increases well i
would say the vast majority of hill
democrats
support raising taxes on the highest
income
and also on corporations as do the vast
majority of americans so
i would flip that question around and
really the question we're posing out
there is if you don't
want to pay for these proposals these
historic
investments in infrastructure these
investments and
ensuring that we are making our
workforce more competitive and
rebuilding roads rails and bridges
around the country
investing in broadband if you don't want
to do it by raising taxes on
the top one percent going back to the
tax rates of president george w
bush raising them on corporations many
of whom never didn't pay any taxes in
the last few years
what's your alternative that's really
the question we're asking uh
most people in the country and and in
the democratic caucus support raising
taxes on the highest income and
on corporations go ahead uh thanks jim
on the infrastructure given that there
were staff level talks earlier in the
week
can you say whether just give us an idea
if the ball has been moved forward
has there been any you know movement on
maybe the pay force you just
you know talked about the importance of
the president's proposal and
asking republicans to submit their own
did they do that is there i mean
was how constructive was this and how
much did the ball move from
where it had been prior to tuesday i
wish there was a daily ball moving
monitor you guys would probably love
that too it doesn't always work that way
as you know with these negotiations and
discussions with members and their staff
our team felt they were constructive
conversations there obviously needed
needs to be followed as we fully
expected because negotiations and
compromise require
many many uh conversations sometimes
back and forth
proposals we expect those to continue
tomorrow those discussions
uh and we're looking forward to that but
i'm not going to be evaluating kind of
the
the percentage of progress after each
meeting
look the president's view and the view
of senior members of this administration
is that
he was elected the american people
expect him to
work with members of both parties to
attempt to work with members of both
parties to get business done
on their behalf and he's doing exactly
that uh so
we're looking forward to constructive
conversations tomorrow we'll have to
evaluate
uh how those go and what the next step
is but i'm not going to get ahead of the
conversations tomorrow
on the 1-6 commission and uh you know
that hangs
in the balance in the senate um you said
just a few minutes ago that this is a
matter of preserving
our democracy uh if it's that important
is this an issue where the president is
going to be lobbying members of picking
up the phone calling republicans
and perhaps speaking to the country uh
you know using the bully pulpit to
push lawmakers on this or is he going to
sort of save
save those calls for for other issues
well he's made clear
what his view is on the uh mark on our
democracy
that was january 6th and he's conveyed
that clearly publicly on numerous
occasions i don't think there's any
secret
about where he stands on the commission
we also put out a statement
on of administration policy on this as
well just a couple of days ago
and certainly as he's having discussions
with members if appropriate
uh he raises a number of issues but i
think it was important for us to convey
where we stand in our view that
this is an issue a commission that
shouldn't be viewed through a partisan
lens and
we don't think the american people view
it that way either go ahead
jen thanks the um texas governor
yesterday signed a
abortion law that banned the procedure
at six weeks yeah what specifically
is the white house looking to do what
specific steps will the bias take to try
and protect abortion access
well first as you noted but for others
who haven't followed this as closely
this is the most restrictive measure
are devoted to ensuring that every
american has access to health care now
more than ever
he continues to support the robust
agenda he put forward during the
campaign to protect
women's fundamental rights including by
codifying roe v wade
obviously there are some actions that
will be through legal
processes and through the courts um
those are decisions for the department
of justice and others to make
but certainly the president uh supports
and
believes we should codify roe v wade and
that is uh his view
uh regardless of these backward-looking
uh steps
that are being taken estates it's by
states in the country
and jen both pfizer and modernist ceos
are saying coded boosters uh
could be needed as early as september
how is the administration preparing for
that in terms of
contracts with companies what would that
mean for efforts to send
shops overseas sure well first we would
wait for the fda
to certainly make that official
recommendation to the american public
i will say that when we purchased such a
large
quantity of supply and doses we were
also factoring in a range of
contingencies
and that includes that potential we
don't know if that will be what the fda
concludes
but we plan for that and in addition to
the supply that we've already ordered
we're going to be focused on continuing
to work with manufacturers to increase
supply global globally of course through
our own manufacturing facilities
and we'll continue to build from the
supply we've already ordered one more
really quickly um last week
25 members of congress sent the
president a letter asking him to
appoint a special envoy in northern
ireland wondering if he has any plans to
do that
and if so what the times will be uh we
did see that letter
certainly um that decision and uh paul a
recommendation probably made by the
state department in terms of what is
needed on the ground
um so i don't have any personnel
announcements to convey or a timeline
for that
go ahead all right thanks um will
president biden press
president moon to join the indo-pacific
quad and if south korea is not a part of
the quad
does that kind of leave a big hole in
your hopes of containing china
well uh the quad has four members so not
to be too mathematical about it but
um i would say that that already exists
um i would say that south korea is um
an incredibly important partner to the
united states hence the president is
having
one of his first bilats in person with
uh the president of south korea and i
think that sends a clear message
now in terms of uh working with south
korea to address
regional security issues or strategic
issues in the region
uh certainly there'll be an opportunity
to talk about that we we expect that
north korea will be a central topic of
the discussion of course tomorrow
but they also will uh discuss uh climate
they will also discuss
uh economic partnership uh they will
also discuss china
and those will all be a part of this uh
bilateral
conversation and meeting tomorrow but in
terms of like a full-fledged membership
i know you'd have to
rename it um is that going to come up is
that is
the president pushed for that look i
think that
uh south koreans may bring up a range of
issues uh of course but i'm just framing
for you what we expect the focus of the
discussions to be about and
i would also convey that there are a
range of forums and formats through the
international
um you know community uh where the us
works with a range of countries where we
work with we may work with of course
japan
and south korea on a range of issues
that there's been history of that
through trilateral cooperation as you
know
uh there are a range of um international
organizations that we are part of and
south korea is also a part of so
i don't have anything to predict or
anticipate in terms of a change in
membership of the quad but
i would just note that the fact that
they are here tomorrow
that it's a full bilateral program uh
makes clear the importance of that
strategic relationship
as president ruled out the possibility
of face-to-face meeting with kim jong-un
of the north i mean is that even
a possibility i don't expect that to be
top on his agenda
do you have any fears that the new irs
enforcement plan might create some
political blow back some wariness in the
public just the idea of the tax man's
coming
i might face an audit um what should
people know about that
well i think one it's one of the reasons
that we want to be absolutely clear
that what additional enforcement from
the irs would be focused
on are people who are not paying their
fair share
that is not hard-working middle-class
americans who are
you know working hard paying taxes
putting food on the table
there are a range of other entities that
are
uh less likely to pay their fair share
of taxes so
um we will be um you know continue to be
absolutely
clear about that lower middle class
americans are for the most part across
the board compliant with their tax
obligations uh but there are cases where
corporations are not paying
their fair share and they're able to
play by their own rules paying half or
less than what they owe
and you know that's really what the
focus
thank you is um on taxes again the
president has called on the wealthy
to pay their fair share i'm wondering if
the president would like to see
reforms to the way that s corporations
are treated given that the
obama administration said that those
corporate structures could sometimes be
used as loopholes and yet
president biden between 2017 and 2020
used an s corporation according to his
tax returns and
reporting in bloomberg to avoid paying
nearly 500 000
in self-employment taxes well i will say
first that
he received no income from us celtic
capri in 2020 which is the s corp
and uh it's dormant and i will not be
engaging in any
business other than to receive potential
royalties which would relate to books he
has already
written and of course as you know you
only know about this because
the president released his tax returns
which uh has long been history
uh historic precedent even if it wasn't
over the last several years uh in terms
of
additional tax reform proposals i don't
have any to announce for you today
i would note that the president paid a
higher rate than most high-income
individuals and most corporations around
the country
and then another one um with regards to
the the question
of what's happening currently in the
middle east i know that you touched on
um you know the iran nuclear deal uh but
you know
there was reporting um earlier
that the leader of the iranian um
revolutionary guard said that the rocket
attacks from
palestine hitting israel was a sign of
quote a new palestine
i'm wondering if that type of rhetoric
coming out of iran has any effect
on uh the president's eagerness to
rejoin
uh the treaty the iran nuclear agreement
and and sort of
if there is any interplay between those
two spheres well i think it's important
to be very clear
iran uh is uh they're bad actors and
they're bad actors in the region
uh and uh we that that is very clear
that is our position
however we believe the president
believes that it is in
the best interest of the united states
and in the best interest of countries in
the region
to have more visibility into iran's uh
nuclear capabilities and to prevent them
from acquiring a nuclear weapon
on the colonial pipeline yes has the
president been briefed
on any intelligence suggesting that the
dark side hacking group
which claimed responsibility operates
under
the indirect supervision of any russian
intelligence services
is there any relationship that we have
seen
i think the president was clear last
week and what the intelligence
assessment is
about the russian government's
involvement or knowledge of
uh the hacking uh at the same time they
are a criminal entity that
uh is uh on russian soil and therefore
they have a responsibility
sure go ahead hi i just wanted to go
back to israel really quick so
yesterday congresswoman okazio cortez
accused israel of using
american weapons to target media outlets
schools hospitals other sites
the other day congresswoman omar called
the israeli prime minister and ethnic
nationalist
i know you've talked about the white
house's
message to democrats but does the
president specifically
denounce these comments i think we have
a responsibility here to speak about
this as a
as it as the issue that it is which is a
conflict that is
killing people uh in a region and and uh
in our efforts to bring that to an end
the president doesn't see this through
the prism of
domestic politics um he sees this
through the prism of
what role the united states can play as
a leader in the global community
to uh to engage in quiet intensive
diplomacy to bring an
end to the suffering and the tragedy on
the ground and
just to follow up on that so of course
this isn't just a domestic issue but
there is infighting
between democrats and one of president
biden's big messages
is unity so what is being done to unify
his own party on this issue
and how is this infighting not hurting
that message of unity well here's where
there is agreement
uh we all want to see an end to the
conflict on the ground
we all want to see an end to the
suffering for palestinian people for the
israeli people
there's a disagreement on tactics
there's a disagreement
on some aspects of how we engage
but we all agree that we want to end the
suffering and
that is certainly a unifying message go
ahead in the back thanks john i want to
pick up on a couple things on my
colleagues of mass infrastructure and
taxes first though on infrastructure
has any progress been made i know you
say that the conversations have been
constructive the talks are going to keep
on going
but has any progress been made through
the lens of the white house
well here's what's progress we have
democrats and republicans the ranking
members
of a range of important committees in
the senate
having discussions with members of our
senior white house team a democratic
administration about
the agree an agreement that we need to
invest in our nation's infrastructure
are we on the same page on every
component of how it should be paid for
or on the numbers
no do we know we'll have a successful
outcome uh
no we don't know that yet because this
is democracy in action this is
compromise this is negotiations and it
looks foreign because we haven't seen
this in some time but
it's ongoing so we're not going to give
a day by day grade it's not particularly
constructive to do that what's the
bigger challenge at this point the top
line figure or the pay for
the top line figure that pay for yeah
what's a bigger
what's bigger lift at this point look i
think uh
i'm not going to rank order them but i
will say that it's not been a secret
that that the largest area of
disagreement is pay force
and obviously if you have a higher top
line number you need more pay fors
doesn't require a mathematician for that
and then um on taxes
the with the guidelines of the treasury
department uh put out today as it
relates to the irs
yeah what is the argument that you would
make that
the inflows and outflows of someone's
account
should be monitored by the irs and since
the since the treasury department says
this
those who make under 400 000 aren't
going to be audited any more than they
have been in the past
essentially are you creating a two-tier
audit system
those who make more than 400 000 and
those who make lots
well i would say that lower and
middle-income americans
who are working hard making getting
their paychecks
are are not uh typically the issue at
hand here and what the uh tax compliance
report
conveyed today is that um
uh or confirmed today i should say is
that it's passed time to reform our
broken
tax system that teachers firefighters
nurse nurses and other hard-working
americans
they report their income they pay
required taxes wealthiest americans and
corporations because they often operate
under different tax
systems it already is a system that is
living in two americas
they are able to pay lower tax rates
that's not fair
that's basically what the president is
conveying
to the person who does well pays their
taxes and just doesn't want
the government seeing the outflows and
inflows they pay by the book and they
say hey i don't
i don't think this is right well again i
think what our focus
is on here is ensuring that any american
pays the taxes that they are owed and if
they're paying the taxes that they are
owed
then they have little to worry about but
there's no question that
uh given that for the last 10 years the
irs has been repeatedly underfunded
currently has 20 000 fewer staff
including fewer enforcement staff
than it did a decade ago uh that uh
proposals like the president's proposal
to increase
uh a 10 increase in funding for the irs
that would largely be used to strengthen
enforcement on wealthy
and corporate tax filers and help ensure
those at the top pay their fair share
is certainly something that i think the
vast majority of americans would feel is
fair and effective go ahead
thank you jen i'm going to bring you
back to the middle east
the u.n chief just said and i'm
reporting him
if there is hell on earth it is the life
of palestinian children in gaza
so far 65 children have been killed 40
women
in total 230 civilians 50 000 people
have been displaced
since this administration for human
rights protection as a forefront of your
foreign policy why can you do more
to protect the life of palestinian
children and exert more pressure
on one of your closest ally which is
israel to
avoid killing children well i would say
that what our effort has been focused on
nadia is conveying behind the scenes
that certainly while israel has a right
to defend itself that
it is time now to bring an end to this
conflict that there has been too much
suffering
too much tragedy every life lost every
one of these children
who has lost their life every family
that has had to mourn the life of a
loved one
is is certainly too many we have
certainly had a shift in our approach
as it relates to our engagement uh with
the palestinians from the last
administration
including uh the fact that the um the
consulate was closed
uh they had ended uh assistance to onra
and during the last administration
and they did not have that open line of
communication engagement they'd also
ended humanitarian assistance and
security assistance the palestinians
which we have resumed
so we have certainly taken a different
approach uh and we believe our
our role here can be playing a role
behind the scenes
uh conveying that it's time to bring an
end to the conflict
and on iran uh talks from vienna is
indicating that
by next round uh iran might come into
compliance
and the u.s might lift the sanction do
you consider that june
18th which is the day of the iranian
election
and it's the end of iran's commitment to
the iea
is a deadline for the white house to try
and to achieve something
well i'm not going to set new deadlines
today i'm sure that won't surprise you
there are certainly political factors uh
that are factors
for uh rent for countries like iran that
are key
parties in these discussions and
negotiations our
of course goal is to mutually return to
compliance with the jcbo
poa and we would be prepared to lift the
sanctions necessary for jcpoa compliance
only if iran
were prepared to return its nuclear
program to its jcpoa status
we will see where we get but that is our
bottom line thanks everyone
you